nabila et son frère chahir détester le
camp de mots rien sur l'île de lesbos
mais ce n'était finalement pas si mal
croit-il aujourd'hui c'est pire que
maurice il n'y a pas de toilettes si
poussiéreux montantes sont posés sur la
pierre il n'y a pas de doute ce n'est
pas un endroit où vivre dénonce nabila
enceinte de cinq mois
paul new york robot ils ont été forcés
par les policiers de s'installer ici à
kara tp dans un camp de fortune
construit dans l'urgence après l
incendie volontaire du camp de moria
dont la réputation d'insalubrité et de
surpopulation n'était plus à faire
les quelques effets personnels que les
frères et soeur venus d'afghanistan pu
retrouver dans leurs tentes abandonnées
ne passez pas l'inspection pour rentrer
à kara tp de ce camp est une prison au
moins à moriat on pouvait entrer et
sortir
ici on est en prison dit haïr en colère
ils sont maintenant plus de neuf mille
demandeurs d'asile relocaliser par les
autorités grecques sur cet ancien site
de tir de l'armée
si nous les avions tous contentés en 14
jours dit ce responsable des migrants
nous serions des dieux nous ne sommes
pas des dieux que des humains qui essaie
d'offrir ce que l'on peut tous les jours
dit il ce nouveau camp occupé quatre
fois plus d'espacé moriya n'en comptait
et des améliorations viendront premier
titre
les opérations sont d'autant plus
complexe que plus de 200 des migrants
déplacer ici ont été testés positifs ou
coronavirus et ont dû être isolé avec
les membres de leur famille dans une
section réservée
les camps des migrants à travers le pays
sont confinés depuis la mi mars pour
cause de lakovic 19 alors que le
déconfinement dans le reste de la grèce
a commencé début mai ils sont mécontents
mais en fait il n'y avait plus d'autre
alternative tout ce qui reste du camp de
maria qui longtemps détesté ce sont les
débris de métal tordue par la chaleur
des flammes et l'odeur pestilentielle
des déchets tout son corps ce plan le
fait avec les gars l'intérêt pour
exploser mon avis nous avions rencontré
delwiche pour la première fois il ya six
mois
il se plaignait alors de la violence et
de l'insécurité dans le camp de noria et
des délais interminables pour que son
dossier soit traité
nous le retrouvons aujourd'hui toujours
aussi inquiet de finir coincé sur l'île
grecque sans jamais pouvoir en sortir
à la suite de l' incendie l'allemagne a
promis d'accueillir 1500 réfugiés dont
le statut est approuvé des familles
seulement et la france devrait-elle
accepté de prendre quelques 400 mineurs
non accompagnés
c'est peu trop peu pour des ong comme
msf qui dénoncent depuis des années les
camps d'accueil où s'entassent les
demandeurs en grèce
les premières réactions qu'on voit sont
quand même très bien très minime par
rapport aux besoins c'est impayés de
l'union européenne accepte d'accueillir
0 point 0 1% de la population moria et
estime que c'est suffisant ça veut dire
qu'apparemment
on n'appelle pas assez à la duff et
n'ont donc la crainte que ça va ça va
juste se cacher à nouveau d'ici quelques
temps et là le haut commissariat pour
les réfugiés soutient ce nouveau camp en
tant que solution temporaire
mais il met en garde contre tout
pérennisation d'une installation
d'urgence le camp de maria aussi devait
être temporaire avant d'être là proie
des flammes
et pour tous ceux qui se sont échoués
sur ses côtes croyant que la mer était
synonyme de promesses et de liberté elle
n'est plus que de l'eau salée il s'y
marie ève bédard radio canada car atp
lesbos